c'est un événement d'une très grande
importance
27 juin 1972 deux ans avant l'élection
présidentielle c'est la naissance de
l'union de la gauche les socialistes et
les communistes adopte un programme
commun pour gagner les élections et
gouverner ensemble si l'on pouvait
régler tous les programmes au tri rapide
membres d'estimer que la vie politique
n'aurait pas sa place deux semaines plus
tard c'est au tour des radicaux de
gauche de rejoindre l'union avec robert
fabre
ça me persuader que ce programme
permettra d'évoluer vers un progrès
économique et social véritable
dès lors les trois partis de gauche font
front ensemble et rassemble tous leurs
militants
mesdames messieurs chers camarades j'ai
l'honneur de déclarer ouverte la plus
grande assemblée jamais réunie par la
gauche nous sommes je suis pour
gouverner
nos jambes fléchies pour l'emporter
rendez vous pour la bataille la première
bataille c'est la présidentielle de 1974
et le programme est clair c'est le
programme commun ya le programme commun
mais tout le programme commun est le
candidat du programme commun c'est
françois mitterrand je suis le candidat
de la gauche
peut-être serais-je bientôt le président
de la république française mais il
échoue de peu face à valéry giscard
d'estaing après l'idylle électorale
union commence à se fissurer aux
élections locales d'abord l'union de la
gauche profite surtout aux socialistes
et puis en 1977 les communistes volt un
durcissement du programme commun une
réunion de conciliation a lieu les 30
négociateurs socialistes communistes et
radicaux de gauche avec leur leader ans
au mythe errant georges marchais robert
fabre disent que très fermement sur les
litiges du programme commun deuxième
édition au cij du parti socialiste mais
ce programme commun deuxième édition ne
verra jamais le jour les divergences
sont trop grandes à la sortie de la
réunion il ne s'accorde même pas sûr qui
prend la parole en premier
moi j'ai des collations à faire genre
premiers le 23 septembre
1977 après une énième réunion c'est la
fin du programme commun cinq ans d'union
à gauche dont la phrase la plus célèbre
restera fait deux georges marchais en
désaccord avec la position de françois
mitterrand sur l'armé nucléaire un
épisode qu'il raconte en 1981 quand j'ai
entendu françois mitterrand refusé de
s'engager sur l'existence d'une défense
nationale
indépendante j'ai dit à ma femme
françois mitterrand a décidé
d'abandonner le programme comment ta
bouche fais les valises on rentre à
paris
[Musique]